hey guys this is dennis the founder
thing here and i'm david griffin your
resident comic looking video game guru
and this is our review of agents of
shield episode 8 the well the big one
the thor TYIN yes the thor suppose it
cross over but really they went to go
clean up the mess that was left behind
in thor to write in common how good he
looks that's about it yeah um yeah I
thought this episode was teasing it was
decent it was a you know how like I was
I didn't review I was sick last week so
I don't review last week's episode I I
felt that was like a step backward yeah
and the one before was a step 4 so I
feel like this is a step forwards again
but they're not you know it's not like
it's been like a sharp uphill an
improvement right i mean it for me this
was my favorite episode even more than
that one where its image jumps out of
the plane whatever I like this one it
most of that happens at the end that I
like a lot but I like the brought an
interesting guest star for once the guy
from ally mcbeal put the doctor the
Asgardian I like he's a great actor alex
been around a long time I liked him and
at least they tried to develop Brandt
grant grant grant co villa remember her
name at least try to develop grant a
little bit i'm not sure if it was a
great attempt but they tried to like
give sure i think that Baxter was better
than his whole like his big brother took
his cake or something like that let's go
that was like a stupid story but but
this thing about the well and and like
his big brother basically forcing him to
not help his his other brother right
while he's drowning I mean and I like
anything to technical aspect you know
Jonathan Frakes directed this he and
doing driving TV for since next
generation for years and yeah he
directed a first contact right well yes
I like the way this one was shot I think
more than some of the other episodes
yeah so I think that the weed in time is
he actually directed a few episodes of
dollhouse okay I really like some of it
these are very capable director you know
if you guys don't know who we're talking
about its commander Riker number one
from Star Trek The Next Generation who
kind of has this nice new career as a
director if you get a good job and I i
think this episode is definitely a
strong one for the series if you know we
can start getting
more episodes like this and furthering a
bigger story line I think then the show
will be a lot more interesting and I
hate to skip over all stuff in the
middle but I think week after week to
suffer the middle of me just like you
know the the people trying to get the
power maybe it's good I really like the
end of this episode the fact that grant
the first person he sleeps with his
ming-na I because now this is just me
look I'm you know in our 30s here so
like I'm not you know I'm not a kid so
when I see a woman may not as a woman so
I'm really happy that he slept with her
before sleeping with sky if that if
there is a choice i like that dynamic is
making us more interesting you know
she's badass she's got like but we got
it here badassness in this episode yeah
somehow she was able to control her rage
and right take on the full Berserker
staff like wait I got this you know okay
okay I'm cool with that not that scene
action wise was well done by jonathan
frakes we're like some of the action in
previous episodes have been pretend a
tweet you know like kind of like yeah
where this one had some some kind of
heft to it and first kind of probably
were the most action heavy Star Trek
movies you know that you know so I mean
he's he's got I mean I think
everything's kind of came together this
episode i hopes isn't the peak of the
show because still needs a lot of work
but yeah good student love it but they
liked it yeah so and i think it's a good
direction that they're going and
hopefully hopefully the you know they'll
get him to come back and do some more
and there and do more episodes like this
where where I feel like the characters
themselves there was more to them mmm it
wasn't like I'm sky the hot hacker you
know oh this you know some someone got
this whatever power I mean they did kind
of that but at least they tied it into
that as guardian thing and loosely tied
to Thor right so you know you and I
right now we're trying to give credit to
the show because we have been
complaining yeah about lack of character
development characters aren't
interesting at least this week they did
attempt to develop such a with grant
who's been I think though I've all the
characters the weakest because he's been
kind of flat you know does not do
anything so I'm glad they tried to
develop his character one more all right
now so uh that's what we thought the
episode did you think that it was a step
up from previous ones who think
do you like where it's going or maybe
you already like the show already I know
some of you are big fans of the show I
I'm kind of more of a wait and see and
I'm still waiting I'm not giving up i
like this episode but I'm still you know
I'm still unsure until it starts getting
like several episodes in a row like good
episodes and in a cool story arc that
brings me back every week yeah I i can
say that i'm looking more for to the
next episode than I was previously right
yeah I mean it's getting better we'll
see ya I don't like get up the oh my
gosh agents of shield is coming on
tonight you have a popcorn ready but I
am this is a better this is an
improvement I have to give the show
credit is getting better this is the
point you started in seven eight
episodes it better at least start acting
like it's getting better I thought to be
perfect but it has to at least start
their else it's you know you can post
your comments below on the website think
Eircom or on YouTube think hero pro make
sure you subscribe to that channel or
you can check this out on Twitter we'll
talk to Dennis myself any of us over
here it's less know what you think he'll
of Marvel Age the shield you know what
do you think the Thor tying you know
just let us know we're at think hero i'm
at griffin de and we also on the
facebook page that's facebook.com slash
think hero fans and make sure you like
that page and share our videos and tweet
them out that really helps out a lot
you